[Music]
hello and welcome to the dead stream my
name is Susie and I will be your host in
this episode I am joined this afternoon
by the fluff of nightmares lady White
Rabbit hey guys and Happy Thanksgiving
to those of us in America I will be
putting out more longer content probably
in January as right now I'm having a bit
of a dry spell but I'm bringing more
content to you guys soon and speaking of
those not in America we're also joined
tonight by the third voice of death
mortis media hey guys hope you will have
a very lovely Thanksgiving if you are
from America and you're listening to
episode 5 of the dead stream we're gonna
take some questions later today so if
you guys want to ask us anything in the
chat we'll be taking a little question
break later in the show and we'll
definitely answer anyone who doesn't
super chat so have you guys seen any of
the recent horror movies we just got out
of October what have you guys been
watching I haven't actually had a chance
to see jigsaw yet very disappointed been
really really busy but it is on my to-do
list
it's gonna be good have you seen it yeah
I saw it a couple of weeks ago so are
you a fan of the franchise I was a fan
of the first and the second one and
after that I kind of just started
watching it for the machines and the
deaths which I think a lot of people do
I think this one was honestly just an
excuse to make another one cuz the
explanation was kind of stupid yeah I
mean I guess we shouldn't go into
spoilers on this show yeah I would
definitely agree that the first and
second are the best ones I like what
they did with the franchise I feel like
kind of has almost Godfather vibe where
they take the formula and keep applying
it to like later in later stories and I
like how they I like the idea of them
keeping it going with jigsaw as an icon
rather than a person sure but it
definitely kind of jumped the shark
somewhere around four or five maybe for
sure and how many times have they
changed directors and producers and it's
it's just gotten a little off the rails
mm-hmm
yeah and that's the other thing I liked
the direction that they were going with
it they had hmm
obviously James Wan directed the first
one and then I forget the guys name
Darren Linn Bausman I think yeah he did
like a bunch of them and it looked like
he was gonna do all of them but then I
like when even he JumpShip then it went
a little bit off the rails yeah and
there's a large gap between the last one
making I think everybody think it was
done and even the people who created it
were like now there's no way we're doing
another one and here we are yeah I feel
like this one it's not like a I feel
like it's a good idea for a sequel but
it didn't really bring anything new to
the table correct yeah but we can stop
talking about it now since more it
hasn't seen it mm-hmm
any other new flicks that you guys have
checked that I don't know if it's a
horror movie but yesterday for the first
time I saw the room because of the
disaster artist coming in so a bunch of
friends got together with me we had a
couple of beers and watch the room
that's the best way to day I've been
meaning to watch the disaster movie is
the disaster artist you know the room as
well I watch I've seen the review by
this guy called I hate everything I
don't feel familiar yeah you know when I
saw the disaster artist I was like I
have to see that I have to see that yeah
exactly
but you've have you seen the room Mart
no no I've been I've been meaning to I
was gonna watch the room and then go
what's the disaster artist I haven't had
a chance but definitely rabbits
definitely got the right way to do it
like with Reds with bears and everything
and totally encouraged
making comments about the movie oh yeah
Mystery Science Theater the whole thing
please I'm actually a pretty big fan of
the room I read the disaster artist book
and I've been to screenings of the room
and when you go to a screening of the
room there's actually like rituals that
oh yeah we threw spoons and stuff we
were trying to get into to screenings
but like it unless you got tickets a
month ahead of time there's no way you
can get into a screening here it's
ridiculous I'm a genetic marker for
those of you who are watching this you
don't know what we're talking about the
room is basically the best worst movie
ever
like the Citizen Kane of bad movies oh
yeah and now that they're making this
new movie the disaster artists about the
creation of the room what do you guys
start on the new Pokemon since we're all
three of us are interested in that I'm
still yet to buy the new the new game
I'll be giving it shortly but I'm really
excited for it I just hope that they
haven't just like kind of done a
complete rehash and it's all basically
exactly the same which it usually is for
the you know for the hood for the Reaper
that they're copies but I just hope
they've gone above and beyond because
when some of them they really did try
and change it and try and make a lot
better like I don't know if any of you
guys played you know Diamond Pao and
then we're not to platinum in my opinion
platinum was fantastic because they
really change it up and made it a sequel
so I know I'm just hoping it lives up to
my expectation everyone in the chat has
got the right idea you're tearing me
apart more yeah I agree with you I feel
like this new one they made it seem like
it was going to be more of a sequel like
black 2 and white 2 or but I'm what I'm
hearing is that it's more of the the
third version of the generation and
there's just two of them now but that's
interesting that you like platinum
because that's probably my least
favorite
like as soon as they started going
because it was a really good like
grounded kind of sci-fi fantasy series
in my mind and then once I started doing
like the oh we're going to a different
dimension it's like that's like so far
outside of what originally was just like
gathering around and going around and
gathering these creatures but you know
what do you have to share about it now
but it's just like in well yeah well I
think that that platinum kind of broke
me and then when Sun and Moon came out I
was like well they've done this before
so I can't really be that mad about it
I've always liked it I just like the
original twist on things you know when
they change things up to me otherwise
it's just like the same game with
different creatures yes well I feel like
that there I feel like there's more that
I can do with like the original concept
so for example I think that they should
do one that takes place like way before
everything else because they keep
setting them like further and further in
the future I think they can do a
prehistoric one they've got like a bunch
of prehistoric Pokemon and it would be
sets like in one of the regions before
the cities are built and stuff and it
would just you would not have to worry
about catching like a thousand of them
because there would only be the
prehistoric ones Pokemon BC catch 21 and
then you would actually have to like use
the APRA corns and create your own
pokeballs I think they could be more
creative about like some of the concepts
was a really good idea yeah so news in
the horror community Rob Dyke was in an
animated series for transformers on go
90 it's called transformers Titans
return and he plays a decepticon named
Devastator so I found that to be pretty
cool there's a couple other fellow
youtubers on there matpat from game
theory Tay Zonday who you guys know is
Chocolate Rain also in the show with him
so the question I want to pose to you
guys is if you had the chance to voice
act in some mainstream movie
so who would you want to play or what
show would you want to be on pretty big
question I might have to think about it
for a moment maybe wrap it you already
know what about you oh I was thinking it
would be do you guys know Metalocalypse
on adults yeah yeah they did four or
five seasons and a movie and they built
it up to this point where it looked like
there's going to be like one more finale
season and it got canceled but I think
it would be really cool to be like
another like a rival band and
Metalocalypse or something or one of
their friends that sounds cool I think
I'd honestly want like a Metalocalypse
of version of rabbit to be in there just
this inexplicable crazy creature shows
up and just talks like hey guys what's
killing us yes or there could be a band
like with a bunch of furries that's the
cool thing about that show is it's
always like it's comedy driven but it's
always like really dark and violent I
think I would go on any show I would
have loved to be on South Park and just
on one of the voices but the thing is
whenever they have celebrity guests they
always made them do stupid things that
they had George Clooney and they make
him play the voice of a dog so you know
I don't know how well it would go yeah I
was watching
I'm rewatching the Futurama series right
now and one of my favorite episodes is
this one where they it's like a clip
show type of thing where they go through
all of these different cartoons so they
parody like scooby-doo and GI Joe and
stuff and there's this clip where the
Harlem Globetrotters are playing a game
of basketball against five Larry Bird's
and Larry Bird's voice is literally just
like his answering machine get him to do
the cartoon
did you think of anything that you would
want to be on rabbit I know somebody
mentioned American Horror Story in the
comments I think that'd be a great idea
I love to be in one of those seasons
that would be more of an acting thing
like I could see you as oh yeah as your
lady by travelpod houses mm-hmm well
that was the first season right haunted
or haunted uh like a like a attraction
haunted houses since that's where my
character came from so other news in the
[ __ ] community our friend Southern
cannibal did finally did a face reveal
or he's calling it a half face reveal so
this is really funny because I think
several months ago he said he may do a
face reveal on Halloween and ever since
then I've been putting pressure on him
to actually go through with it and like
putting out tweets I think we brought it
up on one of the other dead streams and
so he did a live stream a couple days
before Halloween on the 29th and said
he'd reveal half of his face if he hit a
hundred likes on the stream and lo and
behold he actually did it and so we've
got an exclusive photo for you um at
this episode of the dead stream southern
cannibals face so have you guys given
any thought to your own face reveals
well there was a time that I was
considered considering doing it
roundabouts when I hit 20k but since
then but since then I've kind of just
thought I'd wait wait for the time is
right I mean no one's really been asking
for it at all in the comment sections no
one saying do the face really do a face
reverse I'm thinking well I'm not gonna
force something on an audience that
doesn't want anything so you know when
the time is right when when they don't
stop every you know every day asking
then maybe I'll do it then but don't
have to be something special like a
hundred K or something yeah it seems
like the trend of the face reveal has
kind of has kind of waned in popularity
here's the man himself in the chat half
the face said before we get into
questions we're just gonna talk briefly
and I know you guys are probably sick of
hearing about it but we're gonna talk
briefly about net neutrality because it
is pretty important so basically what
the FCC in America is trying to do right
now is pass a law that would allow
internet service providers to treat data
differently depending on where it comes
from so if that happens basically
what'll happen is you'll have different
packages like you do for cable
television so if you want YouTube you'll
have to pay a separate fee to get like
full speed YouTube if you want
Twitter you have to pay a different fee
to get on Twitter so right now there's a
vote that's gonna be happening on the in
it's in early December this net
neutrality stuff is BS so then cannibal
in the chat it totally is you guys have
any thoughts on this yeah screw that
first of all but I think it's their
weird way of controlling like oh people
don't watch TV or cable like I haven't
had cable in years because I have
internet and YouTube is a big source of
entertainment for a lot of people so I
think they're just trying to figure out
how to make money off of that instead of
cable which is going downhill
it's screwed up and it's not cool but
what are we gonna do about it if it
passes and they're already making so
much money it's ridiculous
oh yeah yeah you know what the internet
was made I believe it was you know the
reason that the guy who invented it
didn't charge or didn't you know he said
he wanted it to
for everyone he said it what it should
be for everyone it should be for the
world it should be for the betterment of
the world and putting in something like
this just takes takes that away it's no
longer the free place that it was built
to be which is incredibly disappointing
mm-hmm and you guys don't have to worry
about this affecting you directly yet
because this is just a us thing but if
this does pass in the US then I imagine
it's gonna come over and start affecting
other countries as well oh no doubt no
doubt
what won't it if I hope it's not passed
but if it is unfortunately passed in the
u.s. no doubt you know big consequences
everywhere else in the world you know
that it's not it's not gonna be fun
because I'm sure a lot of the big
companies who own will we manage
information you know that they're gonna
be talking to each other and they're
gonna be not well they're gonna say oh
well if they can do that then so can we
let's get the law passed over here
raspberry yeah yes it's not gonna be fun
for the rest of the world
no no more do you ever look at your
traffic sources yes I do so is 70
percent from the states okay so that's
interesting um if it does pass in the
States I imagine it's going to that
traffic on YouTube as a whole is going
to go down which is like the main thing
that I'm really worried about it is
between the ad pocalypse and we just had
we thought it was over and we just had a
bunch more advertisers pull out
yesterday and this it's gonna be really
hard to pull traffic and make it living
from now on that it's like okay great so
you want to make you want to make money
all your contents a bit edgy oh you want
to make money well we just took all the
advertisers away oh you still want to
make money well now if you anyone wants
to see you it's gonna be expensive
they're just they're just it's like
continual shots it's not it's not good
there's no reason that the Internet
service providers need to profit off of
our work either no I know it's it's not
right I just think it's ethically wrong
like you're over here doing narrations
in a
different country and they're basically
trying to come in and take it cut of it
having done nothing to deserve it
exactly oh yeah you know everyone it's
it's just it's just not right and I mean
YouTube's free because of the advertise
I don't know it's just it's just so
wrong like it's such a big source of
entertainment and so many other
platforms for so many people
I mean think of the millions of billions
of people who use Facebook like then
obviously start doing that as well and
every time you you know if you want to
open the app it'll be more expensive
it's just crazy mm-hmm
so this is the point in the broadcast
that we are going to start taking
questions I was going to be writing them
down but I have only written down a
couple things so if you guys want to
post your questions in the chat we will
start to address those killer person
asks are we gonna listen to two stories
or what we are probably gonna do one
story at the end of the show Harry
Reid's the universe just hates horror
narrators probably because we're
listening to people read hmm I'm not as
literate I just like British accents
says the black eyed blonde fan what do
you think about that whole thing more
like the the American fascination with
British accents I don't know I don't
know every time I see a film or I don't
know it's just funny because English
people usually always protect the
traders these posh you know really fancy
people were there little tea cups and
having tea in the afternoon the
stereotype I get I mean that's a
compliment we're always depicted as like
hillbillies like yeah America yeah
admittedly sometimes be you know we have
like our equivalents but those are never
picked up in any films unless you've
watched Grimsby for example that's only
one I can think have you guys seen
Grimsby now yeah it's a British film I
think made for a British audience but it
takes you to that the worst scummiest
part of England and you just you see it
in all its glory and it's just oh it's
funny so like we have that that
perception of like the stereotypical
British person in America so in where
you are are there stereotypes for other
countries is there like a favorite
accent that like the British fangirls
have I think I honestly don't know you
know it actually might be American
because all of the mood the films TVs
the music you know a lot of it comes
from you guys so it has a big influence
on a lot of the a lot of people here and
they think oh wow it's so cool Newark is
amazing and when people think of America
half the time Wow Hollywood it's so cool
you've got everything there they've got
the freedom they've got you know
affordable housing in a lot of places in
so much face they think of it like wow
America I want to go there I want to get
the green card I want to do my
internship in a American company for a
year and you know just live there and
hopefully get a you know get a residency
that's funny that you should bring up
affordable housing and Hollywood in the
same sentence you know you know you
might also with your kidneys in your
legs but you know in some places in
America I had it isn't that bad so oh
yeah you just can't go anywhere that's
like famous in America yeah I like the
middle of the country I have a great
story about Hollywood so I was supposed
to be traveling I'm originally from
Chicago so I was supposedly traveling
back to visit family for Thanksgiving
and I gave myself usually it takes like
30 minutes or an hour from where I am to
get to the airport at LAX
um I gave myself four hours early I left
four hours early to get there and like
three and a half hours in it was just
clear that I was not going to make it
because the traffic was so crazy
oh so I ended up just like luckily I'm a
Southwest Airlines shout-out to them
lets you cancel your flight and use the
miles later so that's what I ended up
having to do any Southwest people in the
comments anybody so I wrote down a few
questions that people were asking a
killer person asked what country were
from I guess I just answered that for
myself I'm from the US uh yeah me too
I'm not from the US I'm from England I
think we we've brought that up a few
times
Brian Nash was asking if we're excited
for the return of the x-files you know
the making of season 2 of because
they've released it like two years ago
last year but are they're making us a
follow-up of that or they just read
hashing the whole thing we're doing
everything I'm not sure cuz I know they
brought it back like last year or
something and it was a big deal and I've
never been a huge x-files person because
I was probably a little bit too young
for it when it was out in the 90s it
still had a profound effect on me
because like I always remembered like
watching I would watch a lot of shows on
Fox like The Simpsons and stuff and the
x-files would come on and it just had
that really catchy dananana Sunna theme
song yeah
yeah I mean if they bring it back on my
channel watch it it's one of those shows
that I well I grew up with because my
mom loves it she seemed like every
episode at least three or four times so
I used to watch it with her because she
really liked it I think the film came
out at two thousand and eight or nine
and that one was that one was enjoyable
uh you know be a be good if they brought
it back back on mainstream TV or Netflix
or whatever yeah it seems like something
I would be into because I'm into the
like mystery horror kind of stuff yeah
me too it's yeah well the mysterious
stuff is my favorite people in the chat
we're asking about some other shows as
well
scream have you guys seen that no no I'm
afraid I haven't I've seen I've
definitely seen the first scream movie
the other the other scream movies I
don't have a great recollection of I'm
not usually into slicers I'm more into
psychological horror but I like scream
yeah the first movie was good I don't
remember much about the second or third
but I remember the concept was really
unique and I don't know the show would
have the same impact as you know the the
twister the end of the first one was
what got it so different from all the
other slasher movies out there cinder
says she's moderated in the chat for us
today she says they're asking about The
Scream TV series um yeah I haven't I
haven't watched that I'm not really
personally a big fan of them like the
current trend of them downgrading all of
these horror movies into TV series like
I would rather them just make a movie
mm-hmm but we've seen it with scream
have you guys seen the Evil Dead series
ash verse the Evil Dead
no yeah I haven't watched it either but
yeah like I said I'd rather just see
them make new movies
mm-hmm this guy sorry what are you gonna
say I'm sorry I was gonna say up there
Kari said when's the next season of
black mare coming out I absolutely agree
I love that show and I can't wait for
the next season
that's one that I really need to get
into it's real good
I love the Twilight Zone and Alfred
Hitchcock Presents so it seems like that
would be right up my alley and then
whenever I talk about like like if I'm
just talking to people and I have ideas
for something or like what if this
happened they're like oh yeah there's a
black mirror episode about that I love
it that one's on on Amazon Amazon Prime
um it is on Hulu I believe because I
have only I have Hulu and Netflix this
guy phase clown which I'm sure he's an
official member of phase is asking have
we seen it I'm not sure if that's a joke
I just refer back to the dead stream of
one one Episode ago we did do a dead
stream episode where it is in the title
and thumbnail and we talked about it for
like 20 minutes definitely what you
layer face alright we'll take a couple
more questions
Bryan Nash asking about the new
Halloween sequel yeah I saw I saw the
first Rob Zombie one but I didn't really
go anywhere past that Mart haven't seen
it
I'm afraid have you guys seen the the
original Halloween movies yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting I actually have not
seen the original Halloween either
watching is the question rabbit oh sorry
what was it is it worth watching um yeah
I mean they're they're all classic
slashers you know it's up there with
Freddy and Jason and all that so if
you're just looking to
get a good roundedness of slasher movies
than yes I get but like I said I'm not
really a huge fan of the eighty slash
and stuff it's it's as bare-bones as
eighty slashers going in my opinion I
feel like I do have to see it just
because it's so iconic yeah exactly but
uh you know don't expect in anything
that's gonna blow your mind I don't have
to get into it and watch the other
eleven or whatever yeah I definitely
haven't seen all of them I think I
watched him up to h2o or something and
I'm just the the newer ones none of the
newer remakes at the horror movies from
back then are very good in my opinion so
I just immediately not that interested
yeah I actually kind of liked the
Nightmare on Elm Street but the remake
that they did of that was really good
yes alright so we're gonna jump back
into the news a little bit here so there
have been a lot of youtubers
disappearing and dying out so we're
gonna talk a little bit about that
so corpse husband one of our favorite
narrators who has what like 750,000
subscribers yeah he was really starting
to get traction there
he has only posted like what what do we
say like four videos in the last six
months yeah so he's kind of falling off
the map he posted a tweet earlier in the
month and said every time I try to bring
myself to publicly explain why I've been
gone I get so overwhelmed because I
can't fit everything so I'm alive and he
didn't post a video about six seven days
ago but other than that it seemed
strange that a like huge one of the
biggest narrators like that would just
kind of stop posting isn't he the second
biggest behind mister nightmare I think
there's anybody between because mr.
nightmares no two point something
million then there's him you got the the
mr. creepypasta and then
big the big to just always considered
like creepypasta like that olan thing
and this is like the true story stuff
but yeah well that's good we'll just be
a different category yeah well I guess a
lot of people do both though so it's
hard because like mr. nightmare has done
creepypasta as well yeah do it as much
anymore
mmm well the true stuff is getting a lot
more attention but do you guys have any
theories conspiracy theories about what
could have happened
it's a causes corpse husband to stop
posting I don't know there's a little
life things that can go wrong and it
sounds kind of like it might be a little
bit of a personal thing yeah broken up
with his partner it could be anything
with like someone could've gotten sick
you know I hope it's none of those
things I hope it was just like you know
what I need a break yeah me neither just
chill and that's what he's done he's
just like all his shades
he's just sitting on a beach somewhere
for me it would take something like well
honestly I can't think of anything that
would make me stop posting because
that's like my number one priority
so like I don't know to me for for
something bad to happen that would cause
me to stop posting it would have to be
really really bad yeah I guess it's
possible that even though he's a bigger
channel he doesn't like take it as
seriously as we do and like maybe he I
don't know maybe he just needed some
time off from it maybe we don't know if
he has another job outside of YouTube
yeah that's true I mean I know mr.
nightmare at least when I heard his Q&A
he was still doing a full-time job so
for him it was more just a hobby really
mm-hmm
yeah he did upload a video
he go but he used to post I think every
week right yeah I think so
so hitchhiker wounded out recently that
there were a couple of other channels
who were starting to get some traction
who have fallen off the map as well so
this guy and I think this is the the
most fun name to say in the horror
community
scary stuff scary stuff scary stuff
doing great he got to about 10,000
subscribers and just disappeared mm-hm
and has it posted and what did we say
six months yes yeah you get just like
such an impressive milestone and they
just why just no explanation no nothing
and then sinful savant who had about
14,000 totally went rogue and then just
recently I think he posted a new tweet
and said that he was planning on coming
back on Halloween he said happy
Halloween sinful will be returning to
YouTube in the next couple of weeks and
as of right now I don't think that has
happened yeah yeah I mean there was a
guy who I started off with hoot shivers
and he he was he always had more sub
than me and then then one day he just
stopped posting and I got a message from
him an email from him about six months
later saying oh yeah I'm gonna come back
let's do a collab oh yeah let's do it
mm-hmm just stopped emailing me just
called haven't spoken for like over a
year now so it's just a shame like
talent and then just disappear yeah I've
seen like mainstream youtubers do this
as well which is like even more bizarre
because a lot of them have like much
bigger channels than anyone in the
horror community I don't know if you
guys are familiar with this guy gray day
under a he does like the animatic stuff
yeah I think it's almost kind of like a
joke now but he keeps making these
videos saying he's gonna come back and
then he never comes back
yeah does he still stream on twitch I
don't know I don't really follow the
twitch scene as closely now I know that
he did do stuff on Twitch but I don't if
he stopped there as well you did he did
make your saying he would explain it
but he never did right yeah I don't I
can't imagine that he's still on twitch
the last that I saw even if you go on
his Twitter there's like nothing posted
hmm weird I also want to say that Carey
is absolutely right
phantom librarian he disappeared a long
time ago yeah it's time to go he was he
was actually a huge inspiration to me
and then he just kind of vanished
I carry and also said colossal is crazy
is better than great I under a I totally
agree I love I love colossal stuff and
then there was the the big news youtuber
named scarce who didn't tell anyone who
he was doing and one day just stopped
posting for several months and there's
this whole huge meme like where's scarce
I guess that's one of the interesting
things about new media entertainers is
they aren't necessarily like there isn't
necessarily going to be an announcement
and because they have they're run by one
person or a small team then there is the
possibility for them to disappear like
that exactly and then people are left
with burning questions and don't get
answers right hopefully we see
whatever's going on with those three in
the horatii they're able to work it out
yeah soon yeah speaking of the horror
community we've got a lot of milestones
to announce
darkness prevails hit 250,000 so very
exciting for him and so nightmare Expo
has just been blowing up he
does like analysis videos and that type
of thing he when I wrote this down for
us to talk about he had hit 50,000
subscribers and we checked today now
he's actually at 60,000 he's only been
doing this for five months he is on fire
he is on fire that kid he's doing so
really happy
edan hit 30,000 rabbit I know that you
are pretty good friends with her
yeah but not it for a while mm-hmm
have you guys heard of GM Danielson I
think he's got an amazing voice such a
talented and the way he manip and he
could just do so many voices as well
yeah he's yeah yeah yeah he's fantastic
yeah really happy
his milestone yeah he hit 10,000 and
bloodbath and beyond they do like
reviews of horror movies and they like
to specialize with indie horror movies
hit 50,000 I've been watching them for a
while so very happy for them so our last
news piece we talked before about don't
hug me I'm scared on the dead stream and
Joseph telling one of the two main
creators if don't hug me I'm scared
has announced a new character named Todd
the wood so I'm gonna show you guys a
little sketch that he did Oh Todd the
lid so do you think there's any chance
that this is gonna be a tease at the
next season of don't hug me I'm scared
or is this just it's just the character
he's creating and posting on Twitter for
fun whatever it is it has a very short
life span story of Todd the lid here he
looks like a good healthy happy lid and
then what do we call this a Meatwad a
blob yeah this thing next to him it's
like a an emoji we'll just call him
Harry Reid's so sure Todd says I'm going
to have an adventure today Harry Reid
says okay Todd and I don't know these
bricks fall on
and she's dead
so that's top lid I hope you guys liked
him
[Music]
ouch because Frick bricks fell on me
case you needed and now the emojis
flying so like what would be the life
lesson because all of the the don't hug
me I'm scared
episodes kind of have these fake life
lessons for people to learn what would
be the life lesson from Todd the lid
don't watch rings fall okay yeah I mean
that's that's a lesson we should all
hate everybody
don't let bricks fall on your head
terrible terrible thing don't be friends
with Harry Reid's The Blob yeah he
doesn't he doesn't care either way
Todd's all excited about his adventure
and then Harry Reid's is like okay he
has no expression on his face and then I
Todd gets crushed and he's just standing
actually he's just floating there I
guess the the morals just don't go on
adventures it's it's unsafe
it'll be bricks the world is a dangerous
place Kerry says oMG guys stop bullying
Harry yeah you're right we should have
we should have named my character Kerry
call him Harry Caray alright so there's
our last look at the southern cannibal
face reveal again we've just order to
read today I think Mort you said you
were gonna take this one on I will
indeed
give me a minute okay I'm ready
story time I'm ready awkward alright
then freak next door by Adrian Johnson I
lived next to this one kid who always
had bandages wrapped around their whole
head even covering their face
I remember his name was Wilbur I wonder
if it's because Buicks fell on him
Wilbur the twelve-year-old boy who never
left his house he sometimes looked out
of his bedroom window on the top floor
and all of the kids who would play
outside was-- Wilbur sat and watched I
remember his window had metal bars on
them so there was no way he did so there
was no way he could climb out of his
bedroom window poor kid
yeah I'm also concerned as to why you're
creeping into other people's windows
we sometimes communicated to each other
by writing to each other on pieces of
paper
since Walberg couldn't hear me because
the window was locked Warbler only does
it when his parents aren't around since
they're weird his mother and father were
one of those parents who were insanely
crazy about science and chemistry
according to other they would stay in
their basement and work all day and
night except at the times when they
would have to give us some food daily
now they're not treating him like
animals his parents which is very busy
sounds like breaking bad yeah I love her
science and chemistry is always just
like such a generic hobby oh yeah like
there's so many other sections of it but
whenever you hear about it it's like oh
yeah it's the scientist a scientist
don't you casually do science too sure
they told Wilbur that he shouldn't go
outside and make contact with anyone
until his face got better he told me
that he accidentally slipped sorry sir I
just do that see bricks fell on him he
told me that he accidentally slipped on
one of his parents chemicals and fell
face-first ruining his appearance mats
and his parents feared that he would be
made fun of by the other kids in the
neighbor
well I can remember what again like just
not being specific about the science
stuff like his parents chemicals we're
not saying what kind of chemicals they
are the ones I feel like cartoons have
have given us this view of science to
where it's just like people holding lab
like test tubes with various shades of
different colored chemicals and mixing
them and stuff while drinking a jug of
it xxxx right I remember one time a
couple of older kids were throwing rocks
and pebbles at his window laughing and
pointing at Wilbur as he looked down at
them he told me they do it a few times
but he but he's used to it but to me
he's a great guy and still is today I've
never been inside his house but he
showed me some cool stuff he collected
like comic books he had loads of them
from Marvel to DC to other non superhero
comics he was a huge superhero fan he
even said that he felt like a superhero
a normal human being who became affected
by dangerous chemicals I'm looking and
then okay now someone says his parents
were afraid that he would be on failarmy
is that because of his face being
destroyed or because he collects comic
books it's cuz he slips on chemicals
guys fail he once wrote he once wrote on
a piece of paper and had to put it up to
his window as he pretended to be a
superhero I had a collection of action
figures and video games there amazed
Wilbur and he told me that he never
played a single video game in his life
which was quite sad how did he show up
video games if he's on like a second
story window he had a Nintendo swishy he
threw it out no the windows locked yes
he just showed him from the window I
guess yeah good
good vision Wilbur good vision hey
Wilbur this is Pokemon go you can't play
it because you're locked in your room
but it's really fun that's kind of cruel
guys maybe he space we have hope for
Wilbur he also told me that his
babysitter took them away before him
away for him before he could play them
and burden in front of him Boober had a
mean babysitter named miss Fitzgerald a
tall mean lady who never liked kids at
all oh this started before his face
became this stuffy told me she was
basically every kid's worst nightmare
all the things I heard she has done okay
speaking of the the science stereotype
another stereotype is mean babysitters
can you name it I never interested in
her in fiction who's not like a mean
babysitter like she hates kids like well
she's not a sixteen-year-old why is she
a babysitter
Mary Poppins is the only non main
babysitter oh well yeah but things were
different back then
anyway miss Fitzgerald had babies have
many kids before and trust me it was not
pretty
Walda told me the last kid she babysat
the four-year-old girl she made her live
through seven hours of hell Wilbur said
that miss Fitzgerald starved her and
surrounded her bed with a few bear traps
and the worst thing that happened didn't
know about her deed would just lie to
them and get paid how expensive more
bear traps like bear traps are like
pretty easy to avoid so she surrounded
the bed with bear traps I just can't
imagine doing so in a way that you
literally could not avoid
how did she set it up and leave the room
yeah Oh like a cartoon scenario we just
have bear traps lying around everywhere
cuz don't bear traps work because like
you hide them in the leaves and stuff
and then they come in clans like but if
they're if they're in a room like it's
just a room just so messy that he
doesn't know where the bear traps are
all those things I've heard she is a
foul and cruel woman with no soul at all
and now she had to babysit this poor guy
Wilbur was old enough to make his own
decisions except for some but his
parents apparently hired an evil witch
the parents had to go to Texas to a
scientist convention so Wilbur was left
alone with her one time I was writing
about her to show him but then I saw
miss Fitzgerald forcefully pulling him
away from the window and that was the
rest at the scientist convention so
every can we have like like panels and
meet and greets
so like would there be is there like a
famous scientist who would run into the
fountain and cause fangirls to chase
after him maybe this new chemical but
our son's face off and it could do the
same for you who is the Logan power of
scientists I don't know I honestly don't
know hmm
we'll have to find out and that was the
rest of the day without talking to him
the next day when I looked through my
window to see Wilbur I saw someone lying
down on his bed looking at the person's
rapt head I banged on
I'd bang my fist on the window trying to
get his attention
he slowly sat up on his bed wiping tears
away from his eyes he seemed to be
crying which that kick which that gave
me a thought I had a worried look on my
face as I saw bruises all over his arms
and legs a faded dark turn of purple
he went to write something down on a
piece of paper and then warbler finished
writing he went up to the window and
pressed the note on the glass what he
wrote terrified me the whole situation
still burned the back of my mind
something I knew I will never forget
he wrote help me what made it worse was
that the handwriting was scribbled onto
paper and it was almost illegible
Walbert kept banging on the window with
his other hand
then suddenly I saw someone else run
into the bedroom next to him it was her
you know who she had something in both
of her hands big weight chubby hands in
one hand was a lemon and then the other
was a pair of scissors what miss
Fitzgerald did terrified me even more
miss Fitzgerald ran up to Walberg
grabbing his head holding it still I saw
him screaming in pain so I knew I had to
do something but at the same time I
couldn't stop watching
she used scissors to cut open the
bandages and unwrapped them off his head
and threw them to the side what I saw
almost made me vomit something that
sickened me I was utterly shocked
looking at war burrs
real deformed face he was a powerpuff
girl adorable last week I did a video on
creepy things in Pokemon and I was
talking about mimic you so if you guys
aren't familiar with it basically he
it's this Pokemon that dresses up as
Pikachu and whatever is underneath the
is supposedly so terrifying that whoever
sees it dies oh my god
so maybe maybe that's what's under the
rag maybe we're about to find out he's
not a powerpuff girl by the way his
whole head was completely covered by
bandages and one was underneath
I knew the purpose too I saw his face
almost melted off showing a dark red
layer underneath I could only imagine
his face looking like melted cheese on a
cheeseburger
warblers whole face even one of his
eyeballs were burnt a bit there
chemicals had messed him up badly but
she's miss Lamont is very strange to me
she is like I'm just imagining like a
mainstream burger chain like using using
people's faces in their burgers creepy
today you're eating Walberg miss
Fitzgerald sliced the lemon in half with
the scissors pinning Warburton on his
bed then she threw the scissors to the
side next to the bandages she held his
head still with one hand and with the
other hand she squeezed a lemon slice
into Wilbur's head and in his eyes into
the red layer of his face the painful
expression on his face
his loud muffled screams his face
stinging from the acid of the lemon
juice
she used the other lemon to squeeze onto
his face again torturing Wilber with
extreme pain I decided to bang my fist
on the my window which was a bad idea
miss Fitzgerald looked over to the
bedroom window right at me I jumped back
she noticed me she ran back out the
bedrooms shoving Wilber down as she
screamed as he screamed in pain and
agony I knew what she was going to do so
I ran out of my bedroom and ran
downstairs the good thing about this
situation was that my parents did not
know about Wilber and they've
fact and the fact that they were at work
for a little while I locked the front
door hoping the miss Fitzgerald wouldn't
burst into my house I looked around for
the house phone but as I was a loud bang
rang my ears I looked behind myself at
the door noticing her red sweaty face
and her curly blond hair but the look in
her eyes but the look in her eyes I knew
she was going to be trouble
I loved the comment in the chat by
Ashley seriously why waste a good lemon
and bear tracks
she kept banging on the door nearly
screaming her head off as I looked
around for the phone I finally spotted
it next to the couch on the coffee table
I ran towards it dialling 9-1-1 as the
sound of MIT's fitzgerald's threatening
screams were heard from outside waiting
for a few waiting for a few rings I
finally hear the operators voice the
usual greeting from a 9-1-1 operator i
started explaining the whole situation
from beginning to end as quickly as
possible and they told me to wait
patiently as the police would arrive at
my house soon
the writer of the story for actually
putting like a realistic 9-1-1 call we
see so many stories we're like there's
some stupid reason that they can't call
9-1-1 or they call 9-1-1 and then
they're like oh we don't believe you oh
yeah police are useless in most stories
they're only here to be annoying but you
can't write a good story with the police
oh yeah yeah oh yeah they told me to
wait patiently as the police would
arrive in my house soon it took a few
minutes for the police to arrive
not only did they arrive but my parents
arrived early from work as well
apparently they got a call from the
police explaining my situation and
decided to come home it's amazing how
you know they keep parents numbers on
top yeah yeah my parents were extremely
worried and frightened they asked me
more
questions about it than the police did I
had to explain everything from beginning
to end with Wilbur to how his parents
left him with an abusive babysitter and
what she tried to do about now by later
a police officer came to me he had
something he wanted to tell me about the
horrible atrocities that took place next
door
where did Vera found out how old this
kid is no he's ageless because I don't
know usually with these type of things
like they try to they try to keep the
kid from finding out about it so they
aren't scarred or whatever always
already scarred on his face oh I was
listening to 1999 the creepypasta last
night and like the whole basis of that
story is that like horrible stuff
happened but they they kept it from him
and he had to find out about it as an
adult but said I'd be interested to see
how old this kid is let's find out about
an hour later a police offer wait we
were a bit the truth to try another hour
later the police officer came back the
same questions from that same paragraph
the truth about the babysitter the
parents and all that was truly shocking
based on the evidence they found
Wilbur's parents warned his parents at
all they adopted Wilbur from an
orphanage out at that's out of town only
to perform experiments on him it was the
reason why they moved to Texas to hide
the babysitter mitzvos Gerald was part
of the experiment too in fact Wilbur
wasn't the first kid to be adopted by
these scientists they had done illegal
experiments on those orphans and it and
it was good and there was to find out
how much pain a child could take before
death based on the cause of death and
the age of a child 38 children between
the ages of 2 and 13 were reported
missing now mobile was one of them there
were security cameras on the outside in
inside of the house right now they
arrested mrs. Fitzgerald for child
cruelty and the death of many children
for their one look for the missing
children did they check Braska yeah
that's where they should go and on view
and are on the case for the two
scientists all of that and I was friends
with someone who wouldn't have been
killed if I didn't call them who would
have been killed if I didn't call the
police apparently Wilbur tried to lie
about almost everything he told me he
was trying to protect himself he was
sent to a newly trusted family a married
couple who lived out of town since then
I never saw him again until 20 years
later I went to a bar to get myself a
few drinks by myself when a man
approached me remember me he said that
familiar man smiling at me I smiled back
realizing how long it has been since at
last seeing Wilbur in fact he looks like
a nice healthy man now without bandages
how did he recognize you 20 seconds yeah
he was a brown head man with sky-blue
eyes
he almost took like a complete stranger
exactly after that because he was after
that we talked and drank a few glasses
finally speaking to each other in person
Wilbur and I knew that nobody would to
keep us apart the scientists and the
babysitter's are probably locked away
right now after all I couldn't stop
thinking of the fact that this man would
have been killed if I didn't help save
his life listen guys I think it's really
important the story has a good moral
there's a lot of bear traps out there
she carry ourselves yes indeed bear
traps and bricks the leading cause you
know what we don't want you to fall
victim to one
these obvious traps that are everywhere
please just take care of yourself avoid
Graz avoid any grass or leaves the issue
bed that's probably just papers it's
probably just safer to stay in bed just
stay in bed the house don't let anyone
in just keep watching less on you and
just alternate between all three
channels mmm-hmm it's a good idea the I
love the idea of like the crazy
babysitter and the scientists but and I
know this is like the third time that
I've gone back to this but like what was
the purpose of the scientists like what
were when you do an experiment you're
trying to learn something or chief
something so these experiments that they
were doing on the children what were
they trying to achieve with that
mmm they can take pain but can they take
more pain let's find out no it's for
science guys come on maybe they were
actually running like a kids channel on
YouTube and they needed content that's
the reason the advertisers will put out
thanks guys mm-hmm yes your experiment
was to see how much pain the children
could cause mmm the experiments are
conducted on by children for children
lemons and bear trips but a big thank
you to Adrian for submitting that story
I think it's one of the more suspenseful
ones that we've had so far indeed ladies
and gentlemen it seems that our time has
come but don't worry because we're gonna
be doing new dead streams every month
the next stream will be on December 16th
at 2 p.m. Pacific that's 5 p.m. Eastern
at 10 p.m. GMT and we will be joined by
a very special guest
friend unit number five - - is it unit 5
- - or unit number five - - I'll go for
unit 5 too - yeah that's what I usually
say I don't know why I said number this
time the number signs if you missed us
live you can catch the dead stream on
demand here on CDs world for the full
experience where you'll be able to see
the real-time chat and whatever other
images we feel like showing you you can
also catch some recent episodes on
iTunes and Google Play
you know what if it's a unit hashtag
five to zero I was gonna say that say if
someone says it's you now hashtag five -
- you know that really really young if
you have a story or any news about
YouTube or send an email to C's world at
gmail.com and let us know who you'd like
to see me as a future guest the music in
the dead room is composed by OST maker
visit his link in the description and go
ahead and subscribe to us to make his
channel for some more great tunes and
thanks to cinder for moderating the chat
today rabbit where can people find you
on social media
oh you can find me on Facebook and
Twitter I'm just searching the lady
right rabbit and more how can the fans
connect with you on the Internet
if you if you do a little search for at
mortis media on Instagram or Twitter
will find me there you can find me on
Facebook Google+ and Instagram as
Susie's world my twitter handle is seen
these world underscore or and I'm
working on the new merch store which
should be out in the next month so I
will hopefully be able to announce that
in our next dead stream and remember to
subscribe to see these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notification and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you